It turns out that becoming an instant icon
isn't always the greatest thing for a child's
psyche.
Emma Watson, who was cast as Hermione Granger
in the Harry Potter film series at the tender
age of nine, recently opened up to British
Vogue about her years-long struggle with guilt
over having landed the plum role.
Watson was famously plucked from a crowd of
would-be Hermiones during open auditions at
her school, and as soon as Potter fans were
introduced to her in 2001's Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone - or Philosopher’s
Stone in the UK, they knew that the role had
been perfectly cast.
Her droll delivery and adult mannerisms suited
Hermione perfectly, and as the series' cast
grew into young adults over the course of
eight films, it became clear that Watson's
formidable talent was growing as well.
"Boys, I think it's time we teach Weasely
how to respect his superiors."
"Hope you don't mean yourself."
But immediate worldwide fame can obviously
be tough for any kid to handle, and Watson
was no different.
In her conversation with Vogue, the actress
said that she experienced a great deal of
guilt over feeling burdened by said fame when
the role could have gone to any number of
other young actresses perhaps one who would
have handled the exposure better.
The star said:
"I've sat in therapy and felt really guilty
about, to be honest."
"Like, why me?
Somebody else would have enjoyed and wanted
it more than I did."
The actress went on to say that, as a child,
it was truly impossible to know exactly what
she was signing up for when producers picked
her to play Hermione.
"I was nine years old, and I got literally
picked out of a lineup in my school gym.
It wasn't even an acting school."
The star related how, as Pottermania swept
the globe, she had to make a conscious effort
to reorient herself mentally in the face of
massive worldwide fame.
Watson explained:
"And part of, I think, my sense of peace within
myself has been in remembering my identity."
"I belong to a family, I come from a place,
I have roots.
There's a whole really big existence and identity
that I have"
Watson's is a struggle that has been faced
by child actors for generations, but even
among their ranks, a few have experienced
being part of a global phenomenon like Harry
Potter.
Adapted from the wildly popular young adult
novels by J.K.
Rowling, the eight films in the main series
combined to gross nearly $8 billion dollars
at the worldwide box office.
When the Fantastic Beasts spin-off films,
in which Watson did not appear, are factored
in, Harry Potter is the third-highest grossing
film franchise in history behind only the
juggernauts that are the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and Star Wars.
On top of that, the main Potter cast literally
grew up in front of the camera playing the
same characters, a situation even fewer child
actors have had to contend with.
It was a prolonged and intense level of attention
that would have been enough to make just about
any ordinary kid flame out.
But thankfully, Watson and her co-stars Daniel
Radcliffe and Rupert Grint managed to come
away from the experience as well-adjusted,
successful adults.
Watson in particular has continued working
steadily since the main Potter series ended,
appearing in such films as The Bling Ring
and Noah before scoring another mega-hit with
Disney's 2017 live-action adaptation of Beauty
and the Beast, which took home well over a
billion dollars globally.
This Christmas Day, she can be seen in the
latest adaptation of Louisa May Alcott's classic
novel Little Women Despite stiff competition
from the likes of Jumanji: The Next Level
and Star Wars Episode IX: The Rise of Skywalker,
the flick is expected to do respectable box
office thanks to its blinding star power and
the sure guiding hand of writer/director Greta
Gerwig, the creative mind behind 2017's widely
acclaimed coming-of-age dramedy Lady Bird.
Of course, Watson's present success largely
came at the cost of anything resembling a
normal childhood, but the actress seems to
have come to terms with her experience and
the struggles that came with it.
Even if she had never made another film after
the Harry Potter series, she would have been
fondly remembered by fans around the world,
but her boatload of talent ensures that she'll
be gracing the silver screen for years to
come something she no longer feels quite so
bad about.
"It took me a long time, but I'm very happy."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.